en hiver chez William il fait 27 degrés
et il n'a pas le choix car l'immeuble
fonctionne au chauffage collectif dehors
il fait 16 degrés c'est déjà chaud ça
sert à rien que je fais comme ça cela
devient d'autant plus problématique que
se chauffer devient un luxe à cause de
la hausse des prix de l'énergie sa
facture est passée du simple à plus du
double depuis juillet dernier
l'équivalent de 1200 euros
supplémentaires à l'année l'écologie et
la nouvelle religion la parole
dissidente est interdite homme politique
chef d'entreprise intellectuelle
écrivain philosophe artiste sportif tous
ceux qui parlent qui publient ou qui
jouent aucun n'osera franchir la ligne
verte sous peine d'excommunication il
n'y a qu'une vérité le monde court à sa
perte la fin est proche Cassandre et
Nostradamus battent les estrades Cyril
c'est ce qu'on veut montrer tout est
tous ensemble c'est que c'est pas foutu
on peut encore faire quelque chose
non c'est pas foutu mais
je suis désolé en fait je me suis ému
moi-même
il va falloir démolir et reconstruire
Ahmed oui construire d'abord et démolir
après pardon
[Rires]
il avait l'air comment un peu bizarre un
peu bourré exceptionnel
et juste après on va la démolir
l'alcool of the Seas le plus gros bateau
de croisière jamais construit comme un
immense parc d'attraction flottant de
365 mètres de long sur les images de
synthèse toboggan XXL salle de concert
jardin intérieur un gigantisme jamais
atteint vous avez dit moi quand je vois
un bout de glacier qui fond je me sens
comme si je venais de me faire larguer
c'est physique alors je veux savoir
quand vous voyez une forêt brûlée
comment vous avez l'impression de faire
larguer encore plus
difficile on va faire là je m'étonne ce
matin qu'aucune voix s'élève pour
dénoncer des paroles si à l'armistes
qu'elle réclamerait au minimum une
exégèse et là le courage et la valeur la
moins partagée en ce bas monde ça me
rappelle une phrase de Jacques Chirac on
grève de tout aujourd'hui des reins des
bras un cœur sauf des filles par manque
de donneur
décide à la 4e
[Musique]
sa mise à l'eau est prévue en 2024 pour
une croisière inaugurale déjà complète
un projet pharaonique qui ne laisse pas
indifférent
on vient nous taper sur les doigts par
rapport à l'énergie par rapport au
carburant et derrière
on voit des choses comme ça c'est c'est
assez fou c'est déprimant enfin moi j'ai
un enfant d'un an un enfant de 8 ans
quand on voit ça bah on se dit mais
c'est pas possible quoi les gens
réfléchissent pas c'est très bien ça
pour aller à la plage c'est tellement
beau
c'est pas très stable il faut pas trop
se appuyer c'est pas une chaise longue
non mais c'est charmant vous êtes
aujourd'hui sans doute l'actrice la plus
bankable dans le monde et à chaque fois
qu'on vous appelle sur ces sur pour une
prise de position sur l'écologie vous
dites oui vous dites oui même si ça
froisse votre image parfois je vous
remercier de ça vraiment parce que vous
pourriez vous contenter de tourner des
films avec les plus grands réalisateurs
du monde et vous êtes là et vraiment
merci
j'ai pas envie d'être là j'ai pas envie
qu'on soit tous là
on veut pas
qui a besoin de vacances
surmener
surmener très bien
[Applaudissements]
cette rencontre Royaume-Uni France dans
un couloir blanc qu'on dirait
une publicité pour Céline très belle
opération de comme franco-britannique ça
s'est passé dans ce couloir blanc
disposé en T qu'on pousse les politiques
à faire des choses que les politiques
nous poussent à faire des choses et que
je sois plus obligé de venir
[Rires]
libérer Marion Coty
[Applaudissements]
je suis très heureuse d'être là quoi
mais ce serait mieux si on n'avait pas
être là tous ensemble
et tout d'un coup comme s'il se croisait
par hasard dans le couloir pardon
la taxe foncière à Paris va augmenter de
52% 2023 la décision hier soir de la
mère de la capitale Anne Hidalgo qui
renie une promesse de campagne pour
faire face à l'inflation des prix de
l'énergie moi j'estime qu'on devrait
être les derniers touchés quand on est
responsable politique estime qu'on
devrait commencer par laver sa petite
culotte pardon et oui oui tout à fait
raison
les intérieurs et pardon
avec la Bretagne aussi une partie des
Landes qui incarnent qui a brûlé on va
pouvoir grâce à votre générosité on va
pouvoir les replanter merci merci
beaucoup à tous ceux qui nous regardent
ce soir c'est fantastique vraiment je
suis tenté de dire que c'est un
véritable téléron ce soir